[Music]
hello and welcome back to chess openings
explained as always my name is caleb
denby
and i am your host for today and today
we are going over the rest of the
variations in the bishop
e3 line in the night or the english
attack
i also wanted to go over some of what i
went over last week once again now that
i have everything here in front of me
and i actually remember what i'm talking
about
so let's uh just jump into it here
so of course the bishop e3 nidorf arises
after e4
c5 knight f3 d6
d4 takes takes knight f6
knight c3 a6 and bishop e3
entering the english attack and last
week we took a look at all of the lines
involving e5 knight b3 followed by
f3 sort of the main stuff in the english
attack this is the traditional way
that white plays to go for an advantage
trying to push
on the king's site and checkmate the
black
king after bishop e6 for black
white would love to play the move g4 but
unfortunately black can
strike back in the center with an
immediate d5 and a good position
as g4 weakens this diagonal just a
little bit too much
so much better for white is the main
move queen d2
and now i was recommending for black the
uh line that we see actually sort of the
most at the top level these days
with h5 just stopping g4 in its tracks
and from here we took a look at three
options for white in the previous
lecture
we saw bishop e2 we saw the immediate
knight d5
and we saw queen side castles so
uh bishop e2 was sort of i think
one of the better lines for white knight
d5 is kind of just a worse version of
bishop e2
it's a bit too quick to play knight d5
it allows black
to play in
the following manner which i'll go over
in a second actually
but queen side castles is sort of the
more aggressive line
it's the threatening variation to black
where white tries to checkmate him
and we were looking at knight bd7
and here the main move by far is king b1
uh from here the move i recommended was
the immediate b5
and then we got into various different
approaches
for white i should say king b1 is pretty
much always played for white
in these positions your opponent might
start with one of these other options
first followed by king b1
but he's sort of going to owe this tempo
on king b1
until he actually plays it the reason
for that involves
the black pieces coming to the c file
quite early on
as well as threats of this bishop taking
advantage of this pawn being pince
or this pawn on a2 being a bit weak
things like queen a5
can come in some cases as well so king
b1 pretty much
always played for white here and now
after b5
white does actually have i would say
four or five main options really only
three moves get played a lot but then
there are a couple other options that
you might see white go for
by far the most popular here is to go
for knight d5
and this isn't going to be very
threatening for black anymore
the reason for that is we can take this
guy off the board
after e takes d5 thanks to black's
opening
play we can immediately play knight b6
and the pressure on this pawn
is significant enough that white just
has to give up his dark squared bishop
and once this bishop is off the board
things are going to be pretty
comfortable
for white there's simply no other way to
defend d5
so bishop takes b6 queen takes b6
and from here knight a5 is leading into
a pretty comfortable end game rook c8 if
knight c6
we get the end game after knight takes
d5
sorry 97 97 queen d6
takes takes takes knight back to c6
and this end game is just simply fine
for black in fact i would probably
rather have the black pieces than the
white pieces here
and that sort of shows in the database
scores here i don't see
any games that white ended up winning
and there are a few sort of
scattered about that black actually did
manage to win
uh backing up though instead of knight
c6
what happens if white just tries to keep
the position alive with something like
bishop d3 well you're sort of
asking for trouble for one this pawn may
or may not be hanging there's bishop f5
tactics but we don't even have to worry
about all that
black can just continue the game with
something like b4
now knight c4 should be played since
white didn't go for knight c6 on the
previous turn no reason to do it now
when you can no longer play queen d6
and from here the simple queen c5 knight
e3
and after a5 for example black's play is
coming
faster on the queen side than white's
play is elsewhere on the board
and so black is just going to have a
pretty comfortable edge here in these
positions
so how did we get here well we got here
from
this move knight d5 so king b1 followed
by knight d5 is the most popular option
for white in this position but it's very
much comfortable for black
after this idea of knight b6 and then
here really the only way
white plays is with knight a5 if white
tries something else
for example some slow move like a3
black's going to be happy to castle play
moves like a5
play moves like b4 and just pressure on
the queen's side and once again it's
going to be comfortable
for black so instead they all play
knight a5 going for c6 and after rook c8
we either get the end game with knight
c6 and takes or a middle game after
bishop d3
and b4 and black is doing quite well
so that's the main option there's also
f4
this is sort of the plan that you'll see
players with the white
pieces go for quite often against this
h5 idea
h5 of course preventing g4 but
players with the white pieces then
sometimes switch to this f4 plan
because g4 no longer works
and here the best move i could find for
black is actually queen c7 i thought
this was the best way of doing things
for black and the reason is now after f5
black is very happy to place this bishop
onto the c4 square
if this trade ever happens b takes c4
is quite strong when this knight is more
or less stuck
and black or white is going to have a
very tough time on the
on the queen side and if this trade
doesn't happen if white plays
some random move well
once again black is ready to expand on
the queen side with something like b4
a5 to follow as well you can also castle
bring the other rook into the game
and once again black is doing pretty
well here
so f5 is no longer really a good move
after the move
queen c7 much more common is this move
knight to d5 and now we can take on d5
take on d5 and here knight b6
is not going to be quite as good because
f takes e5
is kind of just winning a piece so we
shouldn't play knight p6 in this case
after knight d5 f4 has done a good job
of preventing that
but black is fine with just castling
now after something like g3 trying to
get this bishop to a useful square
rook fe-8 h3 and knight e4
has been quite good for
for black historically here queen g2 for
example
ef4 gf4 bishop f6
and this position has been reached 10
times and all 10 times
it ended up drawn by fairly high level
players
and black is like i said just doing
totally fine here
as for how this middle game is going to
shake out well there are a few different
ideas
for black there's actually an idea of
playing h4
and trying to plant this knight onto g3
that black
can look for black of course can also
look for
the classic queen side pressure with
stuff like a5 and b4
and black can also try and pressure this
pawn just a little bit
play something like knight b6 go for
knight a4 with pressure on the queen
side or just
leave it on b6 with pressure on the d5
pawn
and with all these ideas combined uh
black
is like i said pretty comfortable in
this position in the meantime white is
likely going to try something like
bishop d4 and play for some pressure on
the g file
which is why this idea of h4 in knight
g3 is so common
and is pretty reasonable here
okay so that's the main idea of f4 in
the previous lecture i also mentioned h3
which can be be responded to with h4 to
make sure that g4 sort of never happens
and then from here bishop d3 queen c7
and f4 is sort of the idea but now white
is just sort of
always getting a worse version of the
lines that we just looked at
because black has gotten to play uh
gotten to insert
h4 and h3 which is definitely
advantageous
for black so h3 doesn't make as much
sense
there's also g3 which has sort of the
idea
of either playing f4 or once again going
for a later g4 by preventing h4
and here once again queen c7 is just a
very good move to activate the queen
defend e5 indirectly and prepare knight
b6
knight d5 takes takes knight b6
and we are back back towards that knight
d5 business that we were looking at
earlier
and so these are really uh sort of all
of the main options here
for white after queen side castles and
black is equalizing and in some cases
grabbing a small edge against uh pretty
much
all of them in a very similar way
against everything
okay so that's my recap of the queenside
castles variation i do want to briefly
mention
this knight this bishop e2 move
so h5 here queenside castles we just
recapped also recapping
bishop e2 the idea i wanted to show
last time is
after knight a5 this is sort of white's
only try
to put pressure on the queen side here
my big idea
was to play queen b8 to get rid of this
knight with bishop d8 to follow
in order to challenge this guy and just
one example line that i showed
h4 um sorry not h4
uh i was looking at the wrong thing just
king side castles
and now the point for
white uh sorry the point for black is
that
uh after c3 which is the normal move
against queen c8
bishop d8 there's no knight c4 because
our queen is already defending this
d-pawn this is sort of the improvement
that i came up with and now b5 is coming
very very quickly
and black is better so instead white
should play c4
and after bishop d8 now
rook ac1 for example bishop back to g6
bishop d1 is the best way i found for
white to try to make progress
and here i think knight c5 is equalizing
for black nothing better for white to do
than play bishop c2
except this trade and now we can go
rick e eights white should try and make
something happen while he still can
but bishop takes a5 bishop takes c5
bishop back
bishop f2 and after a5 white has no
real good way of solving these
challenges on the queen side
for example after b5 we can go queen d8
challenging this square
and black is is doing all right here
black probably isn't much better but
black i don't think is worse
either okay so that's my recap of the
previous lecture
of course i did such a long recap today
because the previous lecture
was sort of plagued with some
difficulties involving leeches going
down
minutes before the lecture started so i
sort of didn't have any of my prep in
front of me
but here it is the fully prepped 15
minute version
of that lecture last week so now let's
get into the new stuff
for this lecture there are two new
things i want to look at
one of them is early deviations
after seven knight b3
uh so after e5 knight b3
bishop e7 last week we covered all the
lines where white goes
f3 and queen d2 and now i sort of wanted
to talk about
the other options that white has in this
position besides for going for this
classical f3 queen d2 plan
and then going into one of those three
options that i just discussed knight d5
but should be two are queen side castles
so after f3 white has sort of committed
to this plan
but white can try and improve upon it by
leaving this pawn
back on f2 and
sort of the best i think deviation for
white this early on is this move uh
h3 so i'll talk about h3 but first i do
want to mention
the natural looking bishop e2 is
actually just transposing
to something we've already covered after
bishop e6
and the reason for that is you can also
achieve this position by playing bishop
e2 here
bishop b7 bishop b3 and bishop e6 so
this
has already been covered in the bishop
e2 lecture so check that one out if you
want this is perfectly playable for
white
but it's just a totally different way of
approaching the position
than the bishop e3 lines tend to be
so not bishop e2 here because bishop b2
is a just a different line in the night
or but i think
h3 is the best deviation that still
keeps with the ideas
of the night or or the english attack in
the night or
and the point of h3 is that by using
this pawn to control g4
instead of the f pawn white leaves his
options open
to play f4 with a bit more force meaning
he's not stutter stepping he's not going
f3 f4 he's playing f2 to f4 in one go
not wasting this time that being said i
do
think that black's best response to h3
is still bishop e6 and this might not be
what you expect
if you know a little bit about playing
against
f4 in the night or so bishop e6
is sort of a move that makes f4 a bit
more strong
the reason for that is after bishop b6
f5 is always going to come
with tempo whereas it wouldn't come with
tempo normally
that being said i do still think bishop
e6 is the best idea
because if black kingside castles here
which is the other natural option
then i do think g4 is actually quite
strong and this is sort of
exactly what players playing the english
attack are looking for they're looking
for black to castle
then they can play g4 and play for mate
on the king's side and i just wasn't so
comfortable
looking at all these positions so i am
going to recommend
bishop e6 even though white's idea was
sort of to play f4
anyways and the thinking here is that
it's a lot like the variations with
f4 that we saw in the bishop e2 lines
but in this case
white's tempo that he saved quote
unquote is to put this pawn onto h3
which is somewhat useful but it's not
the most useful and it also weakens this
diagonal a bit
which white might not be so happy about
in the future
so f4 i do think is the critical try
here
but let's take a look at what happens we
take on f4
bishop takes f4 and we can develop this
knight out to
c6 and this is sort of the position that
we have
and in general i do think that these
positions
tend to be pretty uh comfortable for
black if not for white's next move
for example if white sort of just
started developing normally something
like
bishop at d3 black cut castle
queen e2 and something like 95 b5 a5 all
of these ideas
are quite comfortable for black here but
white can sort of force the issue
with the immediate queen e2 this is
kind of causing black some temporary
difficulties if he isn't very careful
for example kingside castles might be
a pretty devastating mistake here after
queenside castles
when there is a lot of pressure on the
d-pawn and
e5 is coming quite uh quite quickly
so rather than king side castles i am
going to recommend the move
knight e5 but the idea being we're
stunting this bishop
uh immediately we're preventing this
pawn from ever
having the idea of moving to e5 and
we're gonna play a few more useful moves
in the center
before we castle our king spending this
tempo to castle
is sometimes a little bit too early here
so queen side castles
and now because we played knight e5 we
are quite ready to jump back with knight
f
to d7 notably if this knight was on c6
and we had castled then the d-pawn would
actually be hanging here
so we play knight e5 and knight fd7
immediately
in order to avoid uh having this issue
and this is a good way of responding to
uh to this queen side castle's idea with
this annoying rook
on d1 uh now white once again
has nothing better to do than play king
b1
he can play something like knight d4 but
this isn't too threatening now
for black he can go ahead and just
castle if he likes
and if this knight lands on f5 black is
usually very happy to take this
but he doesn't even have to here rook c8
is also perfectly playable
and we'll get positions similar to what
we're going to see with white once again
eventually playing king b1 in almost
every case because
these weaknesses with the king on c1 are
sort of just too great
to uh to handle with white
so backing up king b1 first is by far
the most common move here
and now i'm just going to recommend that
black goes ahead and castles
we've dealt with the center enough and
so we can take the time to castle
our king and this is
the one line where
white is actually still managing to play
this g4 move
he does get g4 in here and so you might
be saying well
isn't this what he wanted he played the
english attack he wanted to play g4 i
should be scared now
and the answer to that is i think this
is a very very tame
version of the g4 attacks that white
generally gets
in in the nydorf the reason for that is
this trade of the e
pawn for the f-pawn this trade gave
black some temporary problems
in the center but now that black has
solved those problems he has a very
powerful knight on e5
he's already removed this knight from f6
allowing
the black pieces to control the king's
side and this bishop on e6
is still sitting with some very good
scope here and due to all that
i do favor this position over most of
the positions that black gets
in the standard english attack with g4
coming on the board
uh okay black can play very naturally
now bringing your rook to the open file
with rook c8s
and it's about time for white to try and
develop this piece
so queen e3 now makes the most sense
queen c7 is always an improvement for
this queen
and now i think the most ambitious try
is to play g5 trying to push these guys
forward
for an attack but black is ready to meet
it on the queen side with something like
b5
and play might continue with rook h2
to guard the c2 square knight b6
and now the most common move here is
queen g3 so we'll just stick with that
for the moment
and uh now we would like to play knight
a4
in some cases to get rid of this knight
but thanks to queen g3
this is not so playable notably if
black white hadn't put this rook on h2
then knight a4 would be a very very
strong threat because c2 would be
hanging
but after queen g3 a bit simpler is rook
f to e8s now h4 continues the attack
and will play knight a4 anyways knight
takes a4
b takes a4 knight d4 and
after something like bishop g4 rookie
one
rook b8s it's just a pretty complex
middle game position here uh black
should
not ever really be worse in this
position these open files in front of
the white king in fact mean
uh that black's attack is sort of ahead
of whites as far as time is concerned
but you know white definitely still has
threats on the king's side as well
uh some potential ideas here for black
include dropping this bishop back to h5
to keep things a bit more blocked off
definitely dropping this bishop back to
f8
is always an improvement for black as
well opening up this rook on the e
file and defending this knight
also stepping out of knight f5 and of
course there are attacking ideas like
eventually playing a3
sometimes there's rook takes b2 you can
try and double these rooks on the b
file as well or drop a rook over to c8s
and all of these ideas are
coming into play in in these positions
okay so i will open it up to questions
for just a moment i'm going to recap how
we got here
very quickly so we got here
from this move h3
uh not f3 and the idea is after bishop
e6
now white can launch this pawn up to f4
we saw takes
takes knight c6 queen e2 is the only try
for an advantage from
whites and now we have to play very
quickly in the center with knight e5
knight fd7 and only then castling
then i went on a bit further i think
this is
sort of where you can call the middle
the start of the middle game white
and black can both start deviating here
without too many consequences
but we looked at g4 because it looks
very aggressive bringing a rook to the
open file is very common
queen e3 queen c7 always an improvement
for black to put the queen on this
square
g5 b5 rook h2 knight b6
queen g3 rookie 8 and then we even went
a few moves further with knight a4
as an idea and bishop g4 and then we're
coming back to b8
okay any questions on this line
as i pull up the chat here
why is knight c6 better than knight d7
so in general whenever this trade
happens on the board it is pretty
advantageous to put this knight on c6
rather than d7 and the reason for that
is because it becomes a lot more
important to control the d4 square
in many cases the knight on c6 needs to
control it because this pawn no longer
does
and that on on d7 in this particular
case is also interfering with
the queen's access to d6 and would just
hang upon
but in general whenever this trade
happens it's good to put the knight on
c6
to guard d4 but defending d6
by not interfering with the queen is
also very much a main reason for it
good question
[Music]
doesn't g6 stop white's play
so in that those final positions i don't
like the idea
of g6 and it's for almost the reason
that you mentioned it's because
h5 and h takes g6 is successfully
opening a file
for white once that h-file gets opened
things can get very dangerous
h6 is also an idea like h5h6 for white
but i do think h takes g6
is uh generally a bit more
tough any concern with knight d5 okay
let's take a look
knight fd7 and yeah knight d5 here
does not tend to be uh too
uh challenging for black it's been
played a few times it looks like even
topolof has played this which i did not
actually realize
but we will gladly snag this knight off
the board
and after e takes d5 we can castle
and it's true that white for the moment
has this extra bishop
but there's always these nice ideas of
bishop g5 for example
in many cases to get rid of these
bishops and
activate the rest of black's pieces and
with the straight open e file
black has very natural piece very
natural squares for his pieces
rook takes d5 is also playable to keep
this guy open but it's
going to be similar to the positions we
just looked at just with the exception
of you know these two pieces being
traded off
white definitely can do this should he
do this it's a little
bit unclear but it's not going to change
the ideas in the position the ideas are
all going to be the same
going to play b5 you're going to play
rook c8 queen c7
go for knight b6 to a4 in most cases
also potentially coming into c4 of
course and the same ideas
of stopping white's play on the
um king's side now why doesn't white
do this well i think in general
the knight on c3 does tend to actually
be a reasonable defender of the white
king
and so while the bishop was doing a good
job of defending light squares this
knight was a good defender
as well good question good question
all right let's uh
why doesn't knight takes d6 work well uh
hopefully in all the positions we saw
we are defending we are defending
the d6 pawn um
i'm looking i'm looking i don't see how
the d6 pawn
uh is ever captured all right let's move
on to the next variations so
this was 8 h3 with the idea
of 9 f4 but there's actually a second
idea for white after h3 instead of f3
and that idea is to play the move queen
f3 this is also a perfectly playable
idea
for white however with queen f3
white is very much giving up this idea
of f4
obviously not permanently but for for a
long time
it's going to be a long time before
white manages to move this queen out of
the way
and play f4 so that's the big downside
since white has uh
sort of uh prevented himself from
playing this move f4
i am a little bit more comfortable with
castling in this position
uh once again the idea is actually to
play g4 with queen f3
because you can't play g4 immediately
well you can but it's not very good
because still the immediate g5
is going to be nice and you do still
have this
issue what just happened
what just happened to me
you got there did i close this tab
oh god it's all falling apart that's my
favorite puzzle of all time
is it yeah i showed it in tactics time
all right
we're back i don't know
what series of mouse clicks i just did
to go
to to to mess things up that bad but
we're back all right
uh so bishop takes d5 and you have these
issues of this diagonal being open is
what i was going to say
because of this move g4 so queen f3 is
an attempt at an improvement on that
after bishop e6 queen f3
because now after castles g4 the move d5
isn't going to be as good here
the reason for that is knight takes d5
but now because the queen
is on f3 instead of d1 white can
queenside castle here and black would
get into
actually a pretty fair bit of trouble
so d5 not going to be the idea anymore
what can black do in these positions
well there's a very nice
idea for black in these uh queen f3
lines
and that idea is that white has sort of
diverted this queen away
from the queen's light and so black can
start playing over there a bit faster
and the nice idea is to play this move
a5
uh what is the point of a5 well the
point is
if white plays sort of nonchalantly with
queen side castles
we're playing a4 and this knight really
has no good squares to go to
it comes back to d2 then a3 b3
is just destroying all of all of white's
dark squares
on the queen side and this idea is
difficult to stop
i guess knight c5 is potentially
playable here but the same move is still
going to be an issue
for four white these
dark squares on the queen side are going
to be far too weak
with white or with black getting all of
this sort of with tempo
for example queen a5 is already causing
some very serious
uh issues for white so
white can and should respond to a5
and there are two ways to do it one is
with the move bishop b5 to guard a4
but the more natural perhaps a4 is
actually i think a little bit of a
mistake here
and the reason is while a4 stops a5 kind
of permanently
it is giving up control of the b4 square
and because of that
either knight a6 or knight c6 are both
really reasonable moves
with the idea of using this b4 square
at a later date we don't have to jump
there immediately but we
will be able to jump there in many many
cases
uh there's actually also be rook takes
c3 in this position
with still ideas of the knight coming to
b4 a little bit later on
fun stuff but even immediately knight b4
here
is not at all bad for uh for black
making good use of this square and then
once again it's just going to be a
middle game position where black is
attacking on the queen side stuff like
rxc8 queen c7
and the only change now is that black is
going to have a very active knight on b4
whereas he couldn't so much get this
knight to b4 and many of the other lines
with this pawn on a2
ready to come to a3 so sort of just an
improvement over the normal stuff
for black so that being said
bishop b5 i think is a better try
because now if we try the same stuff
there is always going to be a3 to kick
our knight away
uh now white can queen side castle by
the way knight a6 is
still i think a good move for black and
the idea is now we're not coming to b4
but we are coming
in to c7 and driving this bishop away
white can just move back with something
like bishop e2 but now black
is ready to play something like queen c8
and go for a quick b5
in the future for example g5
knight back to d2 and b5 here is already
pretty good for black once again just
another middle game position
black attacks on the queen side white
attacks on the king's side
uh okay so a little bit of a better try
might be bishop b6
still presenting some opening problems
for black
with the immediate pressure of the
bishops but here we can actually attack
both of white's bishops now with knight
d7 and he will have to give up
one of them in this case bishop takes c7
is better
queen takes c7 and now white usually
ends up playing a4 anyways
now that this knight that was going to
come to b4 is dead
here there are a lot of ideas for black
knight b6 is a very natural move and
after something like king b1
knight fc8 knight d2 for example
just putting some moves on the board
these aren't necessarily forced at all
uh once again it's that same kind of
middle game position right white is
still pushing
up the board on the king's side but the
interesting unique ideas for black here
involve some ideas of occasionally
capturing on a4 actually with b5 to
follow
and i also like this idea of playing
queen c5
uh and coming into b4 with some threats
to the a4 pawn here as well
this this move a4 does still weaken the
b4 square and even if the knight
doesn't jump there immediately it is
very very relevant
black can also occasionally play for
some ideas of d5 here depending on
what white goes for but uh yeah going to
be another interesting
position here as well
um okay so that is this move
queen f3 i recommend we just castle
and it's true that white can play this
move g4
but we're not so worried about it here
because we can just go with a5
and after bishop b5 knight a6 we do end
up
taking off one of these bishops for
white or advancing very quickly
with queen c8 and b5
um okay that is queen f3
and those are the main variations after
white does play this move
uh h3 early on
uh so let's move on
to the next unless there are some
questions
[Music]
why not bishop takes b5
ah okay let me go back to it here sorry
not f4
but this position i assume is what we're
talking about
uh queen c8 something like g5
knight d7 knight t2 and b5
why not bishop takes b5 well this is a
bit um
this is a bit tough this is a bit tough
for
uh for white this is one of the reasons
why king b1
is played so early and so often
yeah okay but black gave up
b5 in return let's talk about
that takes takes here knight b6 king b1
so yeah black is never really going to
be able to play b5
which is why i mentioned some of these
ideas of breaking loose these pawns
using the pieces instead right there's
this idea of knight takes a 4 which is
actually pretty relevant here
and let me just try and show some
example of how that might actually work
let's say sorry let's say knight d2 for
example queen
here rookie one maybe rook b8 even
white passes again for example and
actually okay probably rook b8 here
first
makes a okay sorry hold on hold on if
white doesn't play knight d2
then maybe now the immediate knight
takes a4
is already good and the point is if you
take here
c2 hangs if you take like this then b5
and following it up with a4 and these
sacrifices can sometimes be very very
useful for black that's why i was
playing the move
knight d2 for white so that's one way of
breaking through on the queen side with
this type of peace sacrifice
if your opponent tries to prevent it
some stuff like queen
c5 and like i said queen b4
a piece jumping into c4 could come a
rook capturing on c3 could come
and there's still plenty of ways to
attack on the queen side
for black
okay let us move on then so
8h3 was one deviation that we looked at
there are some other moves
on move 8 as well
actually though i think i've talked
about just about all of them oh yeah the
other thing i wanted to mention
so bishop e2 transposes to the bishop e2
lines which makes sense
h3 we just looked at but there is this
idea of playing queen d2
and after bishop e6 if white plays
f3 and white has directly transposed
to um to the normal stuff here
and sorry let me just get my
bearings really quick
oh yes so sorry if bishop e6 then
f3 would transpose to the normal stuff
but white can actually improve upon this
by queen side castling first
knight bd7 and then playing f4 and so
this looks
a little bit dangerous for black
actually black might be doing okay here
but i do think this is slightly
dangerous
because in this case it's a lot like the
eight h3 lines
but rather than spend the tempo on h3
white has gotten to spend the tempo by
just castling directly and that's why i
think these lines are sometimes a little
bit improved
for white over those eight h3 lines
for that reason here i was recommending
that if white plays the move queen d2
first it actually does allow black to
play this move knight g4
and this is uh sort of just killing the
attack
for white play could continue with
something like knight d5
taking advantage of the fact that black
left the square behind
but now after knight takes e3 knight
takes e3 for example
black is doing just fine after bishop e6
uh gone are sort of the days of this
f3 g4 idea because now the dark squares
are just going to be far too weak
for white because of that the game's
going to switch to be a little bit more
positional with white trying to take
over on the e6 square or the d5 square
rather sorry probably king side castles
now
and for example knight f6
queen d3 castles knight d5
sorry not queen d5 but knight d5
uh rook c8 knight takes f6 bishop takes
f6
and knight back to d2 and after queen c7
this position was totally fine for black
in a position in a game between a niche
geary and darius
sweets and black was doing all right
here
like i said this knight g4 totally
changes the tone of the game it's no
longer really going to be
this english attack classical style
match where uh
white castle's queen side and tries to
checkmate you knight g4
takes off this bishop weakens the dark
squares enough that white has to start
trying to play
for the d5 square but black is going to
be
totally fine and in fact in that example
game i mentioned bishop takes c6 and fe
6 was played
which sort of permanently solves the
problem of the d5 square
for black so this queen d2 move
at first glance looks very clever by
keeping the option open to play f4
but it does just allow knight g4 when
this bishop is
very much stuck on the e3 square
okay with that in mind i think that's
pretty much all the deviations after the
move
knight b3 bishop b7 that white has you
can play h3 to try to be clever
and try to play queen d2 to be clever
you can play bishop e2 to transpose into
the positional bishop e2 lines or you
can go for the main stuff with f3 that
we talked about
now let us talk about something
different entirely which is
what happens when white puts the knight
on this square
instead so that is the next stuff we are
going to look at
so once again all the same opening moves
e5 knight f3 bishop b7 and now bishop c4
is sort of the only idea for white
with putting the knight back on
f3 and the reason for that is the knight
on f3
doesn't really want to be here right
it's sort of in the way
we had all these attacking ideas of f3
and f4
and now those are just illegal because
we put our stupid knight
on the stupid square of f3 and we can't
play those moves
the one upside to knight f3 is that now
the move knight g5
is legal and with this
white tries to make use of this diagonal
to work together with this knight to
control some of these light squares
this is why knight f3 is sort of a move
so bishop c4
is the only idea for white to really
take advantage of this
now black can simply castle
white will castle king's side as well
once again doesn't make as much sense to
try to do queen d2
and castle's queen side here just
because
this knight is very very poorly placed
to facilitate
these attacking ideas and without the
knight on b3
it's much easier now to attack for black
on the queen side as well
so white will king's side castle
and now black is just going to challenge
the center directly with bishop e6
anyways despite
white having these knight g5 ideas it
still does make sense
to just play bishop e6
um okay from here white has
three main options white can capture the
bishop
white can't move the bishop back or
white can defend the bishop with queen
e2
so let's take a look at all three first
and foremost
what happens with bishop takes e6 well
black recaptures
and from here really the only idea
with bishop takes e6 is to follow it up
with the move
knight a4 and the point now
is that white is very immediately
pressuring the b6 square
note that if white tries something like
knight g knight g5 here
the simple queen d7 is defending well
enough and now knight a4 is sort of
prevented forever
which is why people don't play knight g5
first they just go knight
a4 so knight a4 first and how
can black deal with this well i like
not knight g4 which goes into some very
long complications
but knight f to d7 i like this move
just challenging these squares on their
own
and from here if knight g5 now we can
take it so that move has been prevented
but c4 is sort of a natural way of
playing for white to try and lock down
on the d5 square now
but simple development for black is
going to be good enough
for example rook c1 knight c5
knight takes c5 d takes c5 and this
structure
historically has been equalizing for
black it's true that white has a few
targets
with these three pawns looking a little
bit strange but it's well worth it for
black because black is defending
all of these important central squares
with this extra pawn on e6
he never has to worry about a knight
ending up on d5 or any piece ending up
on d5
and with his control over d4 eventually
this move knight d4
is going to come on the board and black
will have good control over the position
in
exchange for a slightly fractured pawn
structure
also notably b6 is a really useful move
for black
in order to defend this guy enough times
to just not have to worry about it
so one way you might see the game
progress is knight e1
queen d1 rook d1 or d8
knight d3 for example attacking both
guys but now b6
is good enough and for example
f3 double double
bishop f6 king f2 and knight d4
and this was enough for a draw in a game
between two grand masters whose names
i'm not going to try to pronounce
well i guess i am going to try glassman
and nymphs
n-i-m-t-z the more you know uh yeah this
was good enough for a draw in that game
and i do think black is doing
just fine in this position tough to
make progress okay
so like i said normal development is
fine there is sort of one problem
that white can try to pose and that's to
play the move queen b3 here
attacking b7 before black gets organized
but this can easily be met with knight
a5 the queen will move to d3
and then i like this reorganizing of the
queen with queen to e8s
it allows knight b6 but it's not such a
big deal
the knight will come back and now black
will have ideas
of queen g6 to follow as well with
counter play on the king's side in
return for this backwards
d-pawn and once again i do think black
is fine for example rick d1
brooks c8s and black is is okay queen g6
to follow
[Music]
um okay so
those were the lines with bishop takes
e6 once again the idea of bishop takes
e6
is to play knight a4 and immediately put
this pressure on the queen's side
but black can deal with it quite simply
by playing knight f to d7
uh stopping knight g5 and also stopping
any piece from landing on b6
c4 is the try for an advantage locking
down all of these squares
but now simple development with this
idea of knight c5 going for this change
in structure with control over the d4
square
okay option number two for whites
instead of taking is bishop b3
just preserving the bishop for moments
and
from here i do like just knight c6
developing this night out
we could come to d7 but then i think you
run into issues
of knight g5 here we need the square for
the queen
so knight c6 instead is perfectly fine
and now once again there are sort of two
ideas
for white white can develop with
something like
queen to e2 but now the idea of knight
c6 is we're going to chase this bishop
and make it make a definite decision
here
and it turns out that this bishop should
no longer trade itself off
for this guy on e6
because in general this does actually
tend to be a favorable pawn structure
for black white can go bishop e6 in the
initial position
because he does get this an immediate
pressure with knight a4
however that pressure is sort of absent
here for example after knight a4
uh we can do a variety of things i think
including the move b5
although no this is this is sort of sort
of an issue here
um for example rook b8 knight g5
gets a little too crazy so not b5 here
but something like knight g4 would work
quite well uh if bishop b6
queen e8s and this pressure on the queen
slide isn't really mounting to much
it's much slower than the first
variation that we looked at for white
okay so instead we see rook f to d1
and be the most common move here
and now black is happy to snatch this
bishop off the board with this
knight a takes b3 queen c7
and bishop g5 and white goes back to
fighting for the d5 square
there's a variety of ways to play here
for black
but the most concrete is actually to
just go
knight h5 when white should try and win
this pawn
but it's just not meant to be after
takes takes
bishop f6 and bishop takes c3 black
immediately regains the pawn
and has some very active pieces
uh two more moves knight d4 work fe-8
and this position is totally fine
and was enough for a draw in godokomsky
against boris elephant
as well as a victory for black actually
in a game between victor bulogen
and zahar effiemenko the more you know
so black doing just fine in this
position
okay and so this is
the idea of queen e2 after bishop b3
white can also play the much more
immediate bishop g5
and now after knight a5 take on f6 take
an f6
and jump this knight into d5 immediately
but
the simple knight takes b3 ab3
rook c8 essentially playing the same way
with black
uh black is once again doing okay here
and maybe the simplest
is to just go bishop g5 and white will
want to kill off this now active bishop
on g5 as it is
controlling some uncomfortable squares
so knight g5
queen g5 and after queen d3 there's a
game between
yu yang yi and magnus carlson from this
year actually where magnus just
snatched on d5 and after queen d5
rook c6 this game was
drawn in the long run with black not
really having enough weaknesses for
white to take advantage of
and white having a couple weaknesses of
his own to deal with on the b
file uh okay
so that is bishop takes e6 and bishop b3
taken care of there's also the immediate
queen b2 that can be played
and here i do like the line of b5
for black once again white shouldn't
take on e6 because now knight a4 is
prevented entirely
but white can go back to b3 and now we
get similar positions
to what we just looked at uh in the
bishop e3 line
black can go queen c7 rook fd1
knight bd7 now is actually going to be
playable
uh the reason being we played queen c7
first and so this stuff
is uh not as good
for white the idea is rook f2c8
knight e6 queen c4 and
we have made a threat to the knights and
a threat to the pawns
if queen c4 rook c4
and white had better start paying
attention to this knight if he doesn't
then the move h6 is trapping this guy
uh pretty convincingly uh okay
so after queen c7 we are able to play
this
improvement knight b to d7 instead of uh
instead of knight to c6 uh the game
might continue
with um
sort of lost my place here the game
might continue with bishop g5
and now uh black is very happy to bring
a rook to c8
and white will be fighting for the d5
square but black is going to be fighting
for knight c5 as well as
pressure down the c file
and those are pretty much all of the
options here after
after this idea of knight f3 so once
again i want to
open it up to any questions that i
talked about today and in fact i think
this
is the last line i had to cover in the
english attack
so any questions you guys have about the
english attack
anything at all in the entire english
attack that you want to know
now is your time to ask me now is the
time
and then i'll do a quick review go
through
hopefully all of the lines very very
quickly
can i recap from 5a6 yeah i'll do that
quickly i'll do that quickly
but any questions at all before uh
before i do
the big recap here
isn't it risky for black castle
before knight g5 i don't think so
i don't think so none of the lines that
we looked at here really involve
black's king getting into
too much danger with the line that i'm
recommending you can get into some
danger if you play bishop e6 first
uh there's some lines here that get a
little bit crazy for example knight t5
queen d7 queen f3 things get a little
bit wild
if you leave the king in the center but
if you castle then
then the black king is is generally fine
um okay well let's uh let's recap how to
memorize it you don't have to memorize
everything
i'm showing very very concrete lines if
that's what you
want if that's what you need is concrete
lines to study then
i am hopefully giving those to you but
uh hopefully you're also understanding a
lot of these ideas that i'm
mentioning along the way the middle game
ideas are just as important
because the pawn storm is an option
uh here it's it's really not an option
and the reason is this this knight is on
f3
uh with the knight on f3 the pawn storms
are are generally always going to be
good
for black for example queen e2 bishop e6
if you try to queenside castle um
already black is just going to be much
ahead on the queen side with these
attacks and once again the knight being
on f3 is very much a hindrance to white
and not
not a help with it blocking the f pawn
uh so yeah these ideas are
pretty much never seen black is just too
fast on the queen slide for these to be
good
please show all the reasons behind every
move i'll try
i'm trying but let's take it from the
top
so we are talking about the english
attack in the night or
which arrives from the main position of
the night or here
white plays the move bishop e3 denoting
the english attack
the move for black is e5 as usual in the
night or
kicking this knight away we just looked
at all of the variations with the knight
coming back to f3
you develop normally the knight goes to
f3 to threaten knight g5
allowing white to take advantage of this
diagonal but black can meet this easily
after castles castles with bishop e6
white then has three main options can
take on e6 can come back to b3
or queen e2 takes on e6 the idea
is the early knight a4 but black can
combat this with knight f to d7
and will eventually play knight c6 and
knight c5
white can play bishop b3 but now black
is going to develop normally with knight
to c6
for example queen e2 knight a5 taking
off this bishop
and once again pressure down the c file
or the immediate queen e2 when you get
very similar things
after b5 and bishop back to b3
queen c7 for example and you can
actually bring this knight out to the
slightly better square
on uh d7
okay so that's knight f3 the main move
though is knight back
to b3 and then from here we start with
bishop e7
we took a look at all the early
deviations with eight h3
where we are still playing bishop e6 and
responding to an early f4
with ef4 and knight c6 taking care
to place these knights on e5 and d7
after the move queen e2 with the early
pressure here
then we castle king's side and it's
generally the the standard play
attacks on the queen side and black has
good activity over here
there's also queen f3 and then here
after queen f3 we took a look
at i believe castles is what i recommend
and
after the move g4 we go for an early a5
and white has to make some concessions
to deal with this namely bishop b5
and then we chase this bishop around and
are ready to attack
on the queen side okay
queen d2 is the only other deviation but
we hit him with an early knight g4
and now this completely changes the
character of the game getting rid of
this dark square bishop
means that white's dark squares are too
weak to try to castle queenslight
so he'll have to play for the d5 square
instead but black
should be just fine that just leaves the
main stuff with
f3 regarding the g4 square bishop e6
queen d2 castles
and sorry not castles not castles don't
castle
uh h5 to stop white's ideas of g4
entirely and then we saw the three main
variations here
with knight d5 which is actually the
most common but i believe the worst for
white
bishop e2 which is uh and it's an
improved knight d5 in my opinion
and the immediate queenside castles
which is the more standard attacking
style game
to go through those quickly i'm just
going to jump
to where i have those things saved the
knight d5 here runs into knight takes d5
takes bishop f5 when this bishop is
fairly active so bishop d3 would make
sense to trade it off but then white
doesn't really have enough attackers
so bishop b2 instead and an early a5
is still a good idea to chase this
knight around for example a4
knight d7 and now
if white still wants to castle queen
slide he's running into rook c8s
and this is going to be awkward so white
should just castle king's side instead
and then we have a pretty easy position
once again
for black b6 knight c5 logical moves to
follow
so that's the immediate knight d5 if
bishop e2
this is an improvement over knight d5
because now after knight b
to d7 knight d5 uh
if we try the same stuff knight takes d5
and bishop f5 what happens here well now
there's this move knight a5
to take over on the queen side that we
would have to
struggle with but in that line
still no need to fear let me jump over
here there's
like i said the knight a5 idea which
shows up here and the idea i introduced
was this move of
queen b8 with the idea of defending the
d6 pawn
with bishop d a to follow to get rid of
this annoying knight
the play might continue with castles
um and what am i recommending castles
and now the standard way of dealing with
the slightly more common queen c8 for
white is to play c3
and after bishop d8 play knight c4 going
after g6
but queen b8 has improved upon this line
by defending d6 immediately
so black would be able to play b5 here
without
issue instead white should go for the
immediate c4
but bishop d8 is still enough for more
or less
equality last but not least let's take
another look at these queenside castles
lines which i reviewed at the top of the
lecture
black will play knight bd7 getting
developed and
king b1 is always a useful move now for
white
and let me just jump this will be easier
if i just jump to where
the actual positions are knight bd7
and now after king b1 we see b5 for
black and white
has a myriad of options including knight
d5 f4
h3 those are the main ones
as well as g3 we'll talk about if the
immediate knight d5 this is the most
common but it's also the least
threatening
because we can take and after knight b6
white has no way to defend this pawn
so bishop takes b6 queen takes b6 is
comfortable
for black knight a5 is pretty much the
only idea
for white but after rook c8 knight c6
knight takes d5 we get a comfortable end
game
for black and this line
takes in knight c6 um so knight takes d5
not threatening at all we go knight b6
and then blight more or less has to play
this knight a5
5 move and black is doing well f4
is the next most common idea and this
idea is a little bit better
switching gears g4 no longer playable
after h5
so f4 instead and there we saw queen c7
giving this c4 square for the bishop if
anything happens
and here white players tend to play this
move knight d5 once again
and we go back to stuff we saw
beforehand
not knight b6 here because fe-5 is good
but castles instead
and now g3 for example black brings a
rook to the center
and there are a lot of ideas here for
both sides just one of which involves
putting this knight on e4
for example and playing bishop f6 when
black once again is ready to challenge
the queen side
okay so that's f4 there's also this move
h3 which you can respond to always
or usually with h4 to make sure g4
never gets played and here white players
generally go back to
these f4 ideas but once again they don't
amount to too much in this case
a lot of ideas of planting this knight
onto g3 as well
last but not least if white tries g3
going for a super slow
g4 or still occasionally f4 this isn't
too threatening we still go queen c7
and now if knight d well for one if
white tries the really really slow
approach of going g4 next
it's just way too slow we have too much
time to play b4 and attack on the queen
side
and if knight back to d5 once again this
knight b6 stuff
is good enough for black if f4 we've
seen this stuff before
as well and now b4 is going to be a good
move
with this idea taking with the knight
and immediate pressure
on the king and that is the entirety of
the night or
english attack in about a five to ten
minute review there
hopefully you guys understand everything
there is to know now
if not watch the two hour review of the
english attack instead of the 10 minute
version
and you might have a better idea um next
week i'm gonna move on to something
different
maybe it'll be the bishop g5 night or
maybe it'll be a different line of the
night or if
who knows but that is my entire coverage
of the english attack
hopefully you guys feel well prepared
against this which is
uh i think now the most common way of
playing against the night or
i think black has some really good
chances in most of these lines
and hopefully you you agree and that's
going to be it for me here tonight
uh on chess openings explained thank you
guys so much
for joining me and as always i will see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you